and we begin with that breaking news a
live look near Fremont Street where
there is heavy police activity at this
time a source telling eight news now
that there was a shooting near the Third
Street stage at the Fremont Street
Experience we're looking live down from
this RTC fast cam now Sasha Loftus has
arrived at the scene you see the heavy
police activities Sasha joining us with
more on what we know so far
section of Ogden and 3rd Street you can
see quite an active scene behind me here
lots of police as you said near the
Fremont Street Experience now Metro
Police saying they are investigating a
shooting involving two people here in
downtown Las Vegas Now sources tell
eight news now this shooting happened
near the Third Street stage on Fremont
Street again a lot of metro police on
scene here again we're at the
intersection of third and Ogden where
this investigation is underway they have
part of this area locked off with crime
scene tape and there are a lot of police
on scene walking around this area of
course stay with eight news now for the
very latest as this story continues to
develop both on air and online reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now